foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck the purpose host of the Ken
Coleman show where he talks about your
career your work all the time every day
is my co-host today so you want to talk
about those subjects he's here for you
and I'll try to stumble around and cover
some of it too the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call and the advice is free and
some say it's worth exactly what you pay
for it Dana is with us in Pittsburgh hey
Dana welcome to the Ramsey Show
praise excited well we're excited how
can we help
well I recently
recently first off I watch you all the
time you Rachel Dr John George love you
guys you've saved my life in many ways
thank you so much I truly respect all of
you well thank you
um
absolutely so I saw something the other
day that said poor people use debit
cards rich people use credit cards I
don't have any credit cards I don't have
any debt I have great Investments I have
money saved up I only have living
expenses I have a great job I don't have
any credit cards should I
well I don't know who said that I guess
it sounds like you ought to stay off a
tick tock yeah you didn't see that at a
Cracker Barrel did you no you didn't say
the Cracker Barrel I promise you you
might have yeah you wouldn't have seen
it there you wouldn't have seen it where
actual rich people hang out or actual
poor people hang out yeah so I don't
know they sound to me like they got that
exactly backwards my net worth several
hundred million and I hadn't had a
credit card in 30 years so I don't know
where they got that
okay so but then don't I need a credit
card to like rent a rental car or is it
I haven't had a credit card I haven't
had a credit card in 30 years
and I travel more than any two of you
put together so
um okay yeah they take a debit card I
mean you have to work some of the
situations you have to work at not every
uh of the rental car companies take them
no and there are some situations where
you have to do a workaround on it but
it's not this idea that you you know so
here's the thing people get credit cards
from mainly one reason
so they can buy crap they don't have the
money to buy
right and then they justify it going
well I need to build my credit
that's what they say because that's what
rich people do rich people build their
credit bull crap all the rich people
that we interview say they get out of
debt and stay out of debt
and that's how they got rich they don't
pay payments all the time because see
there's only one way to build your
credit go in debt right
right why so you can build your credit
why so I can go into debt why so I can
build my credit why so I can go into
debt why so I can build my credit it's a
dog chasing its tail it's called the
Great FICO scam
I haven't had a FICO score in 30 years
really yeah really
that they said I don't exist I'm not
here I'm off the grid
wow because I don't have any credit I
don't have any I have had no interaction
with debt in well over 30 years of any
kind and so I have zero on my credit
bureau report so I have a zero credit
score they they say it's indeterminable
I call it zero
right Dana what do you think you need
credit for what do you think you need a
credit score for right now
if I want to buy a house one day
not true you have to talk to George
Campbell he bought a house with a zero
credit score yeah and he got a mortgage
by the way yeah uh he did it with manual
underwriting it's called with Churchill
Mortgage
and got the same interest rate that
people with an 800 score would have
gotten
but you know what George did don't you
they turned around and paid the house
off
and so at 32 years old he and Whitney
are millionaires
so you know that that's what they did
and it wasn't because he makes a
bazillion dollars here because I don't
pay that good
actually I do but George was Georgia got
it paid off for he started making bank
so there you go but anyway
Whitney makes up the oh yeah two good
incomes there that's it but anyway they
uh yeah so no Dana it's a scam and
whoever said that I mean listen you got
to be careful where you take Financial
advice broke people walk around all the
time with financial advice
don't take Financial advice from broke
people
I mean it's just it's crazy don't you
know you're broke Finance professor in
college just telling you how you need to
do stuff and he's got no money a broke
Finance Professor is like a shop teacher
with missing fingers I mean come on yeah
there's issues here so yeah all right
open phone's phone Folks at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
know Ken what's interesting is if you
look around you say okay the vast
majority of the population is
something I don't want to be yeah then
don't do yeah what they're doing that's
right the vast majority of them look
good and have no money they have cars
they can't afford vacations that they're
still paying for after they got home
their net worth is horrible they're
counting on the government to provide
for them when they get to retirement
because they're not saving for
retirement their children are a student
loan looking for a place to happen
because they're not saving for college
this is normal
in America 78 of Americans live paycheck
to paycheck that means 78 percent of
Americans are not worthy to give out
Financial advice because they're
freaking broke
so when your broke friends have an
opinion just smile yeah no thank you
it'd be like me have an opinion on
growing hair on my head yeah yeah that'd
be dumb yeah I mean if I you know
there's none up there well you could be
an expert on what not to do yeah but I
don't even know what caused it
I can't claim it's DNA so here's what's
going on Dave we live in the claim it's
going broke I could claim my hair fell
out for a lot of reasons but at the end
of the day I'm not good at growing it on
the top of my head so you should not
take my hair on top of your head advice
so here's what I want people to hear
just because it's marketed so heavily
and everybody else has bought it doesn't
mean it's true we have marketing
messages that have been going on for
decades you pick an area of life where
you see a commercial it does take the uh
let's take the prescription drugs they
are marketing these things are good for
you but the list of side effects are
longer than the actual thing it's
helping and but they Market it with
these happy a billion people the
commercial is the disclaimer you know
just know and so it's it's marketing and
so you know we've got to understand that
it's been marketed to you that you need
a credit score it has been marketed over
and over it's the most aggressively
marketed product by time spent on the
air yeah dollars spent on Advertising of
any product in history of humans exactly
right
MasterCard visa and American Express's
combined marketing budget is billions a
year it's way more
than beer right it's way more than I
don't know cars put all the car
companies together it's a tenth of what
the credit card just the credit just the
three credit card companies I'm not
talking about people like so if I who
also advertise to get you into debt or
other people like this it's nothing like
that I mean Bank of America God help us
you know I mean put all those budgets
together to get you into debt oh my God
it is the most marketed product in the
history of the world and guess what it's
also the most purchased
that's why this show is so popular
because people are up their eyeballs in
debt and can't breathe highest
percentage Dave of all time of six
figure earners that are living paycheck
to paycheck and it's largely credit card
debt man when I was a kid if you made a
hundred thousand dollars a year you were
automatically Rich yeah now you're just
automatically in debt this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Olivia is in Indianapolis hi
Olivia welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
so my husband is a software developer
and I'm a ux UI designer and he works
full-time I mom full-time and we are
building this application on the side
for a client but we want to like
turn it into a SAS application like be
able to take on more clients and right
now his most recent proposal is that we
just don't have time to like work on it
I guess
um we have three kids and a house and a
dog and
um he's wanting to quit his full-time
job
um and then get like a part-time job and
then devote the rest of his business
hours to this application
um
and that kind of sounds terrifying to me
yeah I'm a little scared too scares me
what does he make now
uh he makes almost a hundred okay and
what's the client paying you for the
side gig
um well we've made around 15 or 16 000
total but it's not going to be this is
if it's a closed application like I
understand so I understand this is a
one-time application versus software as
a service I understand so SAS you said
correct yeah so you want you want to
launch it out there to other people on a
subscription basis and then constantly
it already constantly maintain it and
Market it
yeah what does it do
uh it's an order management application
okay how are you going to Market it
um so we plan on introducing it at a
conference for like the particular
industry that we're working for
um there's one every year uh it's
usually in like February or March okay
all right so go get two hundred thousand
dollars for the orders at that
conference and then quit
what if we don't have a product that's
good enough to convince anybody
a lot of coffee and put the kids to bed
and work you know when Financial Peace
was written financial pieces sold 3.2
million copies you know when it was
written between 10 p.m and 2 A.M at
night when the kids were in bed and my
wife was in bed yeah way yeah
I mean we've been doing that for two
years now
if you've been working on it for two
years and you still don't have a product
a market worthy product you got other
issues
shouldn't take two years to build
something like this something's not
adding up Olivia so the answer back to
the primary question is no he should not
do this this something's not working you
guys aren't working enough something's
not adding up here he certainly is not
leaving his full-time job making 100K
he's got to work extra hours burn the
Midnight Oil get up early you guys got
to figure this thing out it's not ready
let me let me tell you a hundred percent
of the projects that I have in my head
work
not a hundred percent of the projects
that I have in my head when I put them
out in the marketplace survive as a
matter of fact only about five percent
of them survive 95 percent of my ideas
suck
that's my that's my ratio and pretty
much our ratio of failure around Ramsey
too by the way we try to not let them
suck in ways that cause fatal failure
in other words failure that takes us
down because we bet the whole freaking
Farm on them walking out of a hundred
thousand dollar a year job for something
you wish would work but you hadn't found
time to work on and only made 15K on
it's not wisdom yeah
but do but do go do this by the way go
to live the dream but don't turn into a
nightmare
when's the conference to sell it
February end of February good you got
all kinds of time yeah sit down and say
all right we're gonna we're gonna go
everything we need to do we're gonna go
all in on the Midnight Oil you're going
to go all in on mommyhood and you're not
going to whine about your husband not
doing something because he's working on
the dadgum app
okay yeah for nine months y'all are
gonna go all in and you're gonna take it
at the conference and if it sucks and
you can't sell it all you lost was some
sweat and some Midnight Oil but you need
to be testing this though Olivia you
guys both have the brain power to do
this
so the reason it isn't working you guys
can probably identify we don't need to
spend any time on that but this needs to
be tested tested tested tested before
February yeah you got to get your bugs
you got to get your you got to get built
you got to get the bugs out so that you
can but you need a Marketplace prove it
because right now the only place this is
successful is in your mind
true fully yeah yeah and that you don't
question that you don't quit for that
you quit when you have some proof you
need social proof meaning money
yeah when people pay you money for
something that's when you know it works
until then it's a freaking Theory this
is a business it ain't a hobby
and that's actually a very good point I
if I had the husband on the phone I
would ask him how bad do you want this
because there's the idea of it versus
the actual hard work of sweat tears
blood failure getting back up and and if
you're not willing to do it now I'm not
sure you're willing to do it when you
take a part-time job that's my concern
it's not gonna work it's not you know
what I mean if you can't keep it from it
no no it's a good idea it's worse than
that the thing isn't a business failure
and does not sell right because it was a
wrong right and now he's just screwed
right no that's why you don't take a
part-time job because you just you don't
know listen when you're taking a shower
or you're doing your morning walk or
you're sitting on the back with a cup of
coffee all your ideas are good
they're all good and by the time you get
to the office a couple of them are bad
but not but 98 of them are still good
out of 100. but when you put them out in
the marketplace the marketplace is going
to look at you and go you suck you're
horrible that's a dumb butt idea I'm not
giving you any money for that yeah and
I've had that happen to me in 30 years a
whole bunch of times I mean the stuff
you guys know us for are the five
percent of the ideas that worked the
rest of the ideas are a distant memory
or you never heard of them but they're
psychological scars for me
that's right it's so true if you aren't
willing to lose sleep to lose time with
family to just get an idea proven you
probably shouldn't go after full-time
you got to prove it you got to prove it
because it all works in your head it
always works in your head good question
good question Olivia listen I'm
terrified you need to say that to him
very clearly there's a reason you're
terrified it's not because you're an
irrational person it's because you're
the wiser of the two that's why you're
terrified I'm terrified listen to the
story and I don't even live up there
okay I'm down here so uh you know it is
terrifying what you're describing so hey
all right Ruth is in New York City hi
Ruth what's up
hi Dave hi Ken
um so thank you for uh hearing my
question
um so my husband and I we just got
married a couple of months ago a
combiner finances and everything and
um it's far savings together for a uh
goal of our home down payment and we
have a total of uh 108 000 right now for
a home
um our goal our original goal was to
save up to 230 000 so we could put a
larger down payment for a home and also
have it the closing costs off obviously
and also like a little home emergency
fund
um but I've been hearing in the news
that like housing is going to increase
by like seven percent like the prices of
the houses are going to increase by
seven percent in the next year or in the
next 12 months and a lot of the areas we
want to
purchase a home is like we're like
almost priced and I'm just really
nervous that we're going to be
completely priced out by next year never
buy a house based on fear
okay never are you debt free
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and you have
your you have your real emergency phone
I don't know what your little house
emergency fund thing is but you have a
real emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses
oh yeah we have a six-month emergency
fund how long have you been married
um since May end of May
just the other day
okay congratulations
um if you buy a home in the next year
you're not going to get priced out
you're fine you're fine
you're you're gonna be okay if if five
percent keeps you from buying a home you
weren't getting ready to buy a home
anyway
if I if 50 get your price down but five
percent increase is seven percent
increases don't pressure on the Home
Market
that's all very doable interest rates
can move one point and it changes the
formula right back to where you were
down they'd have to move down one point
for that to happen but I mean yeah yeah
you're fine you're fine you got house
fever because you're a newlywed breathe
be wise buy the right house at the right
time that you're both in agreement to
you've got time you got lots of time
you're gonna be okay sometime in the
next year I would buy a house if I were
you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the
three stage Jeremy and Katie are with us
hey guys how are you hi Dave hi Ken
welcome where do y'all live I'm
Washington Iowa oh fun welcome to
Nashville good day thank you thanks for
having us very cool and how much debt
have you paid off
975 thousand dollars whoa how long did
this take uh seven and a half years wow
and your range of income during that
time uh we started around 180 and we're
around 260 or so now wow what do y'all
do for a living I'm an engineer and a
hog farmer early in the morning
and I work for a hog company doing
logistics for them okay wow look at you
guys amazing great income and 975 over
seven and a half years I'm guessing you
might have paid off the house we did
yeah wow look at it weird people love it
yeah we paid off the house and the hog
building love it what's all that worth
oh
together a million dollars okay and then
how much how much have you gotten your
nest egg
uh 200 250 000. so you're you're worth
over a million and a half dollars yeah
congratulations how old are you two I'm
34. and I'm 32. you're amazing wow
that's real and they just flashed a
picture of the hog building up there
that's no little building that's a
monster
how many square feet is that oh I don't
know it holds 5 000 Little Pigs uh-huh I
bet it does that's a big building yeah
wow congratula and that's what you do
before you go to work that's right yeah
good that's great yeah I pictured in my
head because one look at me you know I
know nothing about pigs but you know I
picture this pin this is a massive
building how many people do you employ
uh just myself what get a little help
occasionally he's an engineer he's got
it all automated okay now little pigs
get fed automatically wow yeah
and then they're not little anymore and
that's the whole idea I like it all of a
sudden I want bacon day
yeah I like it congratulations you guys
are amazing you work your butts off we
did yeah yeah and you still are yeah
yeah wow amazing very very cool okay so
tell us a story what happened seven and
a half years ago how long y'all been
married 10 years 10 years 10 years okay
so a couple years into marriage
something changed what happened yep so
um back then Jeremy drove about an hour
to work and I drove about 30 minutes and
our friend Vince from college tucked us
onto the podcast and said I think you
guys would like this during your drive
and as we listen to the podcast we
thought uh let's let's pay off the car
let's see how that goes and
um as we went we had a couple credit
cards that we paid off each month but we
thought let's pay off the credit cards
and cut them up so we did that and then
uh we tested out doing the budget and
then from there is history we just kept
on going oh so you tried a couple things
it didn't it didn't ruin your life no it
didn't and it kind of got better I think
we can do this yeah yeah you guys sound
like an engineer just kind of easing
into stuff here yeah I don't want to
don't want to break something in the way
yeah you baby step the baby steps I just
want to try this yeah so it once you
finally paid off the credit cards that's
when you were like okay let's try the
budget and the budget changed the game
yeah and you guys got really process
oriented yeah the budget really really
changed uh how we handle our money of
course but how we talked with each other
and how we communicate and work together
uh yeah it really really changed things
for us we're both pretty conservative
Spenders but we didn't really ever talk
about anything
um so once we got four months into the
budget or so it was just clicking right
along so what was the house debt versus
the hog uh building debt yep so we had
about 320 or so on the house and then
the hog building was like 6 20. yeah wow
so were you just pouring profits back
into the building no more or less yeah
yeah but once we paid the house off
especially so right as we started this
we had
um just signed with our contractor to
build our house so we didn't have it yet
so our hog building is about eight years
old and before that Jeremy was waking up
at about 2 30 in the morning to go chore
because we lived about 20 minutes from
there and then he had to come back home
and shower and go to his daytime job my
goodness so we thought we've got to
build a house we have to live closer to
the hog building
so thank God we found your plan when we
did because we uh really tightened down
the budget on what we are going to build
we still built what we wanted but we put
a lot of Sweat Equity into it as we nice
house yeah thank you yeah yeah good for
you guys yeah that building looks I'm
trying to calculate fifty thousand feet
probably
yeah I'd sell I'll call it 250 by 70.
yeah okay all right
does that spitting off oh it does all
right
okay no reason to get in competition no
reason to draw people yeah it's too hard
to work you're not going to have any
competition he has worked himself into a
fabulous situation dude I gotta I want
to honor you for work 2 30 in the
morning can I just tell you yeah that's
some daggum grit yeah good for you dude
yeah so when we built the hog building
so
um we're contract caregivers so we own
the barn and we get paid for our labor
um and then another company owns the
pigs so when we built the barn we
thought we had no risk we thought we'll
do this all day long and then as we
started listening to the show more and
more we realized there is risk involved
there you know the company would grow
for something could happen something
could happen to the hog industry and we
won't be needed anymore and that was a
significant part of our income so well
and you knew that you had to pay that
gun payment on 600 000 bucks yeah yeah
wow no little piggies we got a problem
serious oh my gosh way to go guys
how does it feel to have all of that
done at 34 years old and be free it
feels pretty good great yeah you got you
got some wiggle room now yeah yeah we we
had life happen along the way you see
our our three kids here and then we lost
a six-month-old son oh no oh about a
year a little over a year ago I'm sorry
all right so it you know besides the
hard work it's been a been a ride but
you know without without you helping us
put us in the position we are it would
have been much more much harder yeah I
can't imagine anything harder than that
oh my gosh I'm so sorry wow what
victories and sadness all that wrapped
in together a lot happens in seven years
it does it surely does that's a lot of
ground to cover well done a lot of
wisdom in that now when you look back
did you realize it was good was it
easier than you thought it was going to
be when you get to the end or was it
harder than you thought it was going to
be when you got to the end
um between the two of us it was easy we
knew what our plan was but this is weird
I mean when you're starting to look at
it at first it's like 900 000 bucks
right yeah okay was so when you got to
the end and you went oh my gosh you got
I got this it's easy but it was harder
or that's gonna be really hard and it
was easier which was it
um at points you know when we became the
Nerds and we did the math we knew it was
going to be easy but then when real life
happens and farm ground comes up for
sale around us that we really want to
buy but we can't yet we're not there
um so those were the hard things so the
numbers were both numbers people so that
was easy yeah the emotional side was the
hard thing yeah good for you good for
you what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
I would say you know you gotta work
together if you're not working together
it's not going to work and then working
together but also working hard
um and being disciplined being willing
to say no even though you don't want to
um you know it's all nothing fancy but
um and it works yeah wow Wow way to go
all right bring the kiddos up here what
are their names and ages we have
Caroline she's eight years old we have
will he's six and we have Theo that's
three and what's the name of the one
that's in heaven Lucas Lucas is in
heaven all right perfect guys hey we've
got the live and give bundle for you
that's the baby steps millionaires book
and The Total Money Makeover book and
the Financial Peace University
membership any of that you don't have
you use it if you do have it give it to
somebody it's live and give to say thank
you for coming down you guys are an
amazing power couple yeah thank you and
these kids have no idea about their mom
and dad and how special they are but
they will someday when they look back
and they go oh man paid off the hog barn
by working 2 30 in the morning they'll
talk about you and their grandparents I
like it well done you guys very very
well done all right Jeremy and Katie and
team from Washington Iowa 975
000 paid off baby steps millionaires in
seven and a half years making 180 to
260. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two
[Applause]
wow
what a story amazing
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five Carolyn is with us in
Virginia hey Carolyn how are you
I'm doing great thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
my question is about to paying off my
mortgage early I just retired this month
and I want to know if I need to consider
the tax implications of paying off my
mortgage since the money would have to
come out of my 403 b
how old are you
61. congratulations how much is your
mortgage
uh 145 000. and how much do you have in
your 403 b
once they put in the partial lump sum
it'll be a little over a million
excellent excellent yeah okay you're so
you're a millionaire look at you way to
go yay what's your what's your house
worth
about 550. way to go are you single
no I'm married okay well so that's your
household situation or your personal
situation
my personal situation my husband has a
403b that's about uh two hundred
thousand and
um he has Social Security and I have a
pension that will
um help us live okay all right yes
you'll pay income tax on the hundred and
forty thousand that you pull out so uh
calculate that in and pay off your house
today
really absolutely
tax bracket that doesn't matter for one
year Zippy it's not it's not much money
so the the deal is this okay it doesn't
the way we can tell to do this is if
we're wrong
it doesn't matter you're still in great
shape
okay if you told me you had 250 000 to
your name that was your whole Nest Egg
for your whole family
and I was going to clean out I don't
know 200 of the 250 to pay this house
off I would have pause on that because I
don't want to get you down to no money
thank you it doesn't matter that the
mortgage is only at two percent or
anything doesn't matter nope doesn't
matter because you want to be free
that's why you've worked this hard I
really do I really do if the mortgage
being at two percent mattered you would
have borrowed another another 400 000
back when it was a two percent but you
didn't go further into debt because it
was so wise to have a two percent
mortgage
right the same apply just because it's
smaller doesn't mean no no or not keep
it it's not a pet
it's kind of it's not as ugly as other
pets but we're going to keep it no no no
no no no it's still ugly okay yeah all
right yeah because think about what
you're going I mean if you if it was
paid off and you had instead of a
million you had uh I don't know when you
have 800 000 in there okay
and you wouldn't go borrow money to put
it in Investments
no no yeah same thing even if you could
borrow money even if you could borrow to
two percent so you're free you're free
you're free you did so good you were
young hey how much of your well I know
it's in 403 b so you didn't inherit this
money
no I didn't inherit any money no this is
all just what you do for a living
is your return I was an educator in a
public school I was a principal of a
elementary school there it is yep there
it is hey well done love it
congratulations I'm so proud of you okay
by the way number one career field for
uh millionaires in the millionaire
largest millionaire study ever done done
by Ramsey Engineers hog farm guy okay
engineer number three teachers Carolyn
okay I mean come on and teachers can't
be millionaires well you just probably
ought to call Carolyn up and tell her
that then oh my gosh apparently you can
be apparently somebody did it so there
you go teachers number three number two
accountants number four business
Executives number five lawyers
doctors empties didn't even make the top
five
they're notoriously stupid with money
it's like a stereotype they're like
music people or something they're I'll
tell you what the truth is the truth is
docs are like music people the music
people in Nashville that I know there's
one or two types dumber than a rock with
money or genius
that they don't really there's no middle
ground and I find the same thing with
MDS the MDS are really smart with money
or they're just arrogant and stupid it's
just nuts and they almost broke doctor
yeah you are you worked your whole
stinking life to be a doctor and then
you're broke yeah because you get often
they apply their
oh well anyway yeah the way to go yeah
this flies in the face of the notion
that the American dream is dead that you
can't get ahead this is just a woman and
her husband who they just lived on less
than they made they live like no one
else and now she's gonna live and give
like no one else and it's just I love
these stories because you don't see this
in the news you don't see this data
point six hundred thousand dollar paid
for house
now right uh eight hundred thousand in
her now 403 b he's got 250 so they got a
million dollars in cash that's right and
a six hundred thousand dollar paid for a
house that we know of their net worth is
1.6 that's right that we know of 61
years old
um and doing just fine thank you very
much
doing just good it's better than not
Millions dollars is not enough you help
us more new God
so maybe you ought to go get it and then
talk about whether it's enough or not
everybody everybody's got a deadgo
opinion about something they've never
done right you've never ridden a bicycle
you should not criticize bicycles I mean
come on this is do do something that and
then talk about it oh you just said
something beautiful go get it is what
you said people want it given to them
they want the higher salary they want
all the stuff given to them but they
can't manage it when they do get it
given to them these are people these
everyday millionaires uh uh baby steps
millionaires they are the people that go
get it they get it but she didn't it
wasn't like some big no it was like
steady the tortoise not the hair Taurus
not the hair Jamie is in Washington
state hi Jimmy welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Ken and Dave
um my question is is my husband and I
are expecting to receive over a million
dollars in a buyout situation and we're
not sure what we should do if we should
take it away
I wish but I'm not that type I'm kidding
you just couldn't resist I was like I
sure wish you could do I think I think I
find something okay wow what happened
something was he hurt or something what
happened
um no we were my husband was involved he
had a partnership in a business and they
decided to buy him out oh cool that's
awesome
okay so you got a million bucks and
you're trying to decide what to do with
that
correct and we owe a 3
3 okay and
around that okay well then we got 600
left because we just paid off the house
now what are we gonna do how old is he
um he's 40
. awesome what's he gonna do now
we don't we don't know the we kind of
feel like the
options are open
um infinite yeah I got 600k to play with
yeah let's go do something
we're not interested in maybe staying in
Washington so but interest rates were
concerned to move
yeah well you don't have an interest
rate if you have a paid for house
my interest rate's zero because I don't
have one
correct and yours is two now so what's
your house so where are you moving
um we would like
from or you can buy a house for cash in
Idaho they'll let you do that
okay sell the house you got sell the
house you got and put some cash with it
and buy you a house for cash in Idaho
now what's he you don't know what he's
gonna do for a living yet
yeah no not yet okay all right what
should we take it in one lump sum or
yeah sure about taxes yeah they don't
want him around I'd get I'd get my money
away from them
okay they might they might screw this
thing up and not be able to pay him
later
correct yeah
okay whoa I just hit a nerve
yeah correct
yeah yeah get your money now yeah you're
gonna have a little tax on it but oh
well
such happens when somebody gives you a
million dollars but not gives you but
you earned a million dollars and yeah
pay your pay cash for the house or step
one step two is develop a game plan
because he does need something to go to
not just from yeah this is not his
defining moment it's his first it's the
First Act what's he gonna do in the
second act and the third act in The
Encore when he comes back out on stage
and the Applause continues I'd like to
give him a gift Dave I'd love to give
him the get clear assessment along with
from paycheck to purpose as he figures
out the path forward this is a great
time for him to go what do I do best
what do I love to do what results do I
want to put in the world he now has the
freedom to do that yes like a whiteboard
not quite poor you can do anything you
want to do and you got the money to go
do it this is very cool it's a great
time Jamie I know it's sad for y'all in
a lot of ways but you really ought to
just be smiling this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
certain want to know more about getting
started on the Ramsey Baby Steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation again that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
and amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality host of the Ken
Coleman show number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
career and jobs and work expert open
phone is my co-host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Mary's in Chicago hi Mary welcome
to the Ramsay show hi thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
I have a son who was accept accepted to
an Ivy League Law School
and I know 10 things that you say you
should never do is take out student
loans
um
to go to school and we paid for all of
his undergrad
um everything we'd save through a 529 24
plan and
um
good way to go yeah he's taking out
quite a large sum of money about a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars for
three years he did get ninety thousand
dollars worth of scholarships
but I just am really nervous
about that I mean that's a lot of money
um and coming out of where he's going
he's in a t-14 school
so
his income in three years when he's
finished will be 200 to 250 000 maybe
you hope
well that that's what big law is paying
in in New York and Chicago and that's
where he would end up based on what
um he's a top student and 100 of the law
students that graduate from that
University do not go into big law
well he he the reason he chose
is because it's International and that's
what he wants to do I know but 100 of
the international law lawyers who
specialize in international they
graduate from that law school do not
make a 250 000 salary some do
but not all of them do
so anyway this is already decided How
can we help because we can't fix it I
mean he's gonna go do it
well
I just wanted to kind of
find out
what you thought and also why it doesn't
matter he's doing it anyway it does
because we have a coach house over our
garage and I did offer to him that when
he got done he could live in the coach
house but he would have he would have
three years and he would have to pay
that back in three years he would have
to take all other than his minimal
living expenses and pay down that debt
is that something you think we should
offer him or be like nope you took it
out because we never had student loans I
paid for all my school myself
um Mary if you want to offer a chicken I
don't think the guy that signed up for
the trip you're talking about is going
to take your offer
okay
I think you would do that you would live
in the coach house but I don't think
this guy will
do you think it was a mistake to do that
what he's done yeah absolutely
but I don't think it matters all we can
do is love him I'll love him and you can
love him and and hope it works out for
him but um it's it's mythology that you
make more money because of where you
went to school across the board now
obviously there are exceptions to that
and coming out of Harvard Law does set
you up to be a better chance than coming
out of
University of Tennessee law school okay
to go to a big firm in Chicago or big
firm in New York but also you've got to
understand when you sign up for big firm
in Chicago big firm in New York you're a
number and their goal in the first three
years there is to try to kill you right
right you worked 300 hours a week I mean
it's just bizarre it's crazy yeah and
all just to get to be in big law I mean
it's and then at the end of the story
what have you really got when it's all
clear oh I'm a partner in this mess yeah
okay uh and
um so it's it's it's if that is your
goal singular goal uh you know you might
make If he if it all works out and he
does get that gig then we might get
there might but I I want you to hear
this Mary and I want Dave to comment on
this because diving into this is a new
study out by a group of harvard-based
economists
opportunity in sights and they looked at
students who were waitlisted by Ivy
League schools Dave compared with the
estimated future earnings of those who
eventually got in with those who didn't
and they attended one of nine Flagship
public universities instead so you
mentioned University of Tennessee and
here's what they found
it just sticks to a statistically
insignificant impact on their future
earnings as the projected income at age
33 and they said that the ivy league
degree would average a three percent
increase over a state school no that's
not law
it's not law but they're talking about
but they're talking about in general in
Ivy League a hundred percent I I can
tell you that in business it doesn't
make spit difference 78 of the fortune
500s are state of the Fortune 500 CEOs
graduated from State School
they didn't go to MIT they didn't go to
Wharton and they didn't go to Harvard
and they didn't go to Yale okay and they
didn't go to Vanderbilt and so the idea
that you make more in business is
laughable now in law there is a nuance
that you probably can get in there she's
talking about big law she's correct
about that and this is the pitch he's
but the the problem is he still has to
get in just because he had the degree
from Harvard he's got to get him
graduate well but he still graduated in
the top of his head he's got to graduate
he's in he's in he's got the degree he's
got sure he's got the entrance right and
he's written the check it's a done deal
so Mary just coach him and tell him hey
we love you
and we're going to be here for you even
if we don't agree with your decisions
and we hope it works out for you the way
you think it's going to but I but I'm
worried for you and I'll be praying for
you honey yeah because I will I'm not
mad at him and I'm not mad at you folk
out there but the problem is when people
believe mythology that two percent of
the people you know if you do something
that only works two percent of the time
that's not a principle that works
that's correct and you know so what
percentage of Harvard Law or Vanderbilt
law or for that matter and you pay you
pay
what 4x for the degree or 5x for the
degree of what you would have paid in a
state law school uh and then to get into
big law and what percentage of them by
the time they're 33 are still there
right that haven't got ground up like
last week's hamburger with a schedule
they put them in right and just destroy
them uh so I mean it's it's legendary
how mean they are to the first and
second year uh people on and I want to
point out this is like it's like playing
division one football or basketball yeah
you still got to make it to the NBA and
so here's the point he's going to come
out I know he's in the school but I'm
talking about once he's out
he's got to compete against all those
other Ivy Leaguers that are competing
for the same big law jobs so it's not a
guarantee that's what you got to be
careful about all it guarantees is is
that they may look at you because these
big law do tend to prefer ivy league
grads yes but you still got to compete
agreed gotta win and then are you really
at the end of the day going to earn that
much more
on average no I don't know if his
particular Narrow Path works out for him
yes he will yeah yeah I I'm not going to
argue that part of his his agreement but
based on that what I tell my own child
to go 200 000 in debt oh crud no not
even close what I tell you to pay on
what I what I tell you to go into that
to go to an Ivy League a famous school
just because no no no no no please don't
all the data tells us Harvard Economist
did a study on themselves and said it's
not worth it
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I think it I just feel the need to
Circle back for a second
um
number one
if you are going into a field
where an education is needed we are huge
proponents
of a four-year degree we're also huge
proponents of the trades
there's lots of guys that are welders
that are making 120 000 a year while
people with a master's degree in social
work are making thirty eight thousand
so let's just keep in mind what you're
going to earn when you go get a degree
so when you're studying don't study some
left-handed puppetry degree get a degree
in German polka history there's only one
job if you have a degree in German polka
history you have to get a PhD so you can
go teach other people to get a degree in
German Polk history it is the only
possible use for that degree and there's
crap like that all over the place that
people go and do and in the name of all
education is good no all education is
not good for purposes of earning now as
all education expand the Mind
hypothetically some of your minds are so
empty that it's crazy you shouldn't put
stuff in there but um but the uh but but
some of it you know so generally
speaking education is a good thing
generally speaking a lifetime of
learning is something you need to engage
in a hundred percent of You Yeah a
hundred percent of us need to engage in
a lifetime of learning if the last time
you read a non-fiction book was five
years ago shame on you turn off Netflix
go read a non-fiction book for God's
sakes learn something all the time for
the rest of your life learn something
read read read read all leaders are
readers
not all readers are leaders but all
leaders are readers so be doing you know
learn learn learn believe in education
all four of my kids got a four-year
degree but the the thing that
universally you cannot defend there is
not one shred of data except mythology
that going to a high-priced famous
School ivy league as an example
that you can justify the extra expense
okay the versus a high of well staffed
well-run State School the University of
Ohio the University of Georgia the
University of Tennessee the University
of whatever you know whatever state you
want to put after that okay or just a
state school in you know the Middle
Tennessee State University as one of the
best broadcast and music degrees in the
world and it is a state school and it's
like eight thousand nine thousand
dollars a year tuition
okay one of my friends is a president of
a major Network sent her kid to MTS to
Middle Tennessee State University in
Murfreesboro freaking Tennessee and
could have could have afforded to send
their kid anywhere but wanted to study
broadcast and one to study the field
that the parent was in and so you know
what we're looking for here is value in
education because education is important
but this idea that you have to go to a
famous School
because it's going to get you a job or
because it's going to get you more money
is statistical mythology there's nothing
to back it up lots of studies saying
it's not true yeah it's virtually
insignificant even in the higher level
grad degrees and this is not our opinion
these are Harvard economists that have
put this stuff out so and that's the
customer doesn't care by the way the
only people that carry your mom and dad
and your grandparents and maybe crazy
Uncle Larry at Thanksgiving because
that's where he went to school you know
so we've got to get over this my nephew
went to Cornell I couldn't give a crap
nobody cares yeah did he learn anything
yeah there's two things that we teach
here one is a degree the only way to get
where you want to go to do that thing
you want to do or is it the best way
if it's no to both of those simple
questions is it the only way or the best
way then I got news for you there's a
different way and increasingly in 2023
it's a whole lot less expensive and a
whole lot less time consuming and that's
the reality of the world we live in and
it's only continuing to shift that
direction yeah so we're pro-education
absolutely it just doesn't always
require a degree we're not pro mythology
yeah and it doesn't require a degree to
be success you are not more likely to be
successful by going to one of those
famous schools yeah it just isn't there
there's no data again Wall Street
Journal did a full survey 78 that's 8
out of ten of the CEOs of Fortune 500
companies the top 500 companies on the
stock market graduated from State
schools you know what though you are
statistically significant hello
I found I realized just a second ago
that you are more likely if you go to
one of those big name schools you are
more likely to be broke I shared a story
on the Ken Coleman show just a couple
weeks ago of a guy who went to Columbia
okay Film School oh
three hundred and forty thousand dollars
because he went undergrad and he got a
graduate level degree he's in Hollywood
making sixty five thousand dollars right
now and he was quoted in the Wall Street
Journal saying I could have got this job
without either the four-year degree or
the Master's Degree oh he's exactly
right he could have yeah and so now
that's again that's the film industry so
it's not apples to apples in every
industry you got to have a grad degree
for medicine for science a lot of your
science jobs and a lot of your and
obviously all medical jobs but uh
there's a guy who regrets it and he got
this prestigious degree and he still had
to start at the bottom if you want to
get a business degree at Vanderbilt
University in our town here the southern
ivy league if you will sure it's seventy
thousand dollars a year University of
Tennessee is twelve thousand dollars a
year so we're saying six times is that
is that degree six times more valuable
at Vanderbilt than it is at the
University of Tennessee I'm a hundred
percent sure it's not because I graduate
from the University of Tennessee and
people that graduated from Vanderbilt
work for me
oh by the way football team's better at
UT well that football that's it that's
but yeah I mean it's just I just had to
throw that in I know it has nothing to
do with what we're talking about
absolutely nothing don't pick your
school on your football either that
don't do that don't I'm going to please
God that's a very good play school
because they have a good foot which by
the way a lot of kids are doing that
party scene yes it's always rated and
everything it's just all this garbage
man so it whether it has a lazy river
there's schools that have a lazy river
that you can Coast down you can float
down a lazy river at a university this
is how asinine this whole process has
become and this is why we have a student
loan debt problem of trillions of
dollars because Congress continues to
make loans to people who want to go to
the lazy river
there you go open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five see if
we can squeeze this one in our question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly's Nationwide Network for
locally owned home service pros like
Molly made Mr Rooter plumbing and
five-star painting takes the stress out
of home repairs maintenance and
improvements visit neighborly.com to
schedule a service today great company
today's question comes from Tony in
Massachusetts I recently applied for a
job that I'm extremely qualified for and
thought I had a serious shot at getting
the interview never got a call and I'm
growing a little discouraged it's an
amazing job which I'm sure has a lot of
competition the application process went
through an artificial intelligence
platform that screened my information
and I'm worried it screened me out the
whole process felt impersonal and I feel
like I didn't get a chance to convey my
skills and experience do you have any
tips for applying for jobs under an AI
platform it's been a while since I've
been in the job market yeah so this is
an applicant tracking system even small
businesses are using some type of AI
software to help process information so
we've got an entire article that I wrote
on this called how to beat applicant
tracking systems this is at
ramseysolutions.com but I'll just pull
out a couple quick things for uh Tony
one you've got to use keywords so if you
read a job description let's say it's
about a three or four paragraph job
description you've got to be paying
attention to keywords in the description
Tony and then you make sure that those
are in your interview
so for instance if it says you need a
lot of experience with Excel just using
a simple example then make sure one of
your skills on your resume is Excel so
that that AI System picks up on that
second make sure that you edit every
resume to be custom for the job a lot of
people are doing a cut and paste and
putting out multiple resumes multiple
jobs that'll get you flagged and then
third don't apply for too many roles at
one company one roll maybe two Max don't
do six or seven sometimes that'll get
you kicked out as well but again more
details in this article we go into great
detail can find somebody you know inside
the company like the whole thing using
proximity well we wrote an entire book
called The Proximity principle it says
that's more important you need to know
somebody in the company or know somebody
that knows somebody so that they take
your resume old school style fast AI put
it on the highway
well we don't want him saying look at
this Goose he's a good one oh a good
goop all right use proximity principle
get the book that's that is the answer
to circumvent anything that has
technology problems this is the Ramsay
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
foreign Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Greg and Meredith are here hi
guys how are you doing well how you
doing better than we deserve welcome
good to have you where do you guys live
Boston oh wow welcome to Nashville thank
you and here to do a debt free scream
how much of you paid off 425. all right
how long did this take five years good
deal and your range of income during
that time 2 30 to 4 30. excellent wow
nice jump yeah very good what do you
guys do for a living I'm an attorney and
I'm in sales in the HVAC industry
awesome yeah I hope you didn't go to
Harvard after we just did all that
we were talking about it though man
after we did all that that would have
been the irony of irony yeah I went all
the way to Nashville to do my debt free
stream I'm freaking from Boston and yeah
that would have been great I'm glad I'm
glad it worked out though good hey how
much what kind of debt was the 425 all
student loans Foster every dollar every
bit of it so uh attorney uh law school
and uh yours as well private school for
me yeah private school good okay cool
good for you guys what do you do for a
living an attorney you said and you said
you're doing what I'm in sales and HVAC
sales and HVAC excellent good good okay
so how long you been married
almost six years this year so right
after you get married something you say
okay we're gonna we're gonna plow into
the student loans tell me the story uh
well you were on the Ben Shapiro show
and I never heard of you before no idea
anything about it years ago about that
yeah almost six yeah so I kind of got
the idea of you know this guy makes
sense started listening to your podcast
started subtly playing it at home when
Meredith was in the room and I know that
I don't make the decision I get Meredith
to make the decision when I want it to
be made
you should write a marriage book yeah if
she likes the idea in advance you know
we do we do what I'm hoping we're gonna
do so
wow yeah it did lead to the the only I
would say argument in our entire
marriage wow yes
um I wanted to go to from baby step one
straight into two and take what was
already a done baby step three and drop
it down to baby step one so I wanted to
put every dollar that we had you wanted
to follow just a thousand dollars
exactly into our student loans but
knowing that we were going to do five
years we compromised and we did her plan
okay I'm sure you did it anyway yes okay
well you make a great income and you
both were in agreement ultimately and
got after it yep yep okay very cool
congratulations thank you so when you
got 425
000 worth of student loans that's a
Mount Everest and you get married and
you're looking up and you're going holy
crap this just got real yeah
puts it takes your stomach and does not
yes oh yeah yeah
so was the
five years easier or harder than you
thought it was going to be
once we made the plan I think it was a
lot easier than we thought it was going
to be it didn't seem as insurmountable
as once we actually just got started
because we were on the same track full
time looking down from the top of the
mountain down is much easier than
looking at the bottom oh going on yeah
but when you get up there you're like
Dad Gum this was a harder climb than I
thought it was going to be right or wow
that was I thought this was gonna be
horrible and we just did it you know so
you know you never know which way it
comes out would not do again but no yes
I'm not signing up for this trip again
no this is not it's not my definition of
a vacation no no we did have the
advantage too because Meredith's income
was enough that we were able to live on
no problem so we were able to just take
my entire income and throw it at it so
we we did Dave ish for a little while
and I know that's a story a lot of times
but basically we were able to to take
what she was already making live only on
that and then say Okay anything that's
left anything that's my income and then
anything extra we can get out of hers
we're just going to throw it straight at
it my observation is is that when things
start working people start sacrificing
deeper absolutely once they get hooked
and generally that doesn't always happen
yeah because I'm curious when in the
five-year Journey does the income bump
significantly or was it gradual it was
pretty gradual when I got a promotion
from associate to senior associate that
was a very large bump and that helped a
lot and we were able to throw my extra
income into the student loans and that's
what really propelled us this last a
little bit nice a good chunk of my
income as commissioned so I also got
better commissions over time so what
kind of sacrifices did you guys make on
this journey uh waiting for children
we're not waiting anymore
congratulations thank you very fun
that's not easy to wait on is it it is
not it's not an easy choice to make but
sacrifice was definitely it was worth it
to now that weight is gone yeah have our
son and be really excited about him and
not have the debt on top of it right
yeah and his mom and Dad paid a price to
change his life absolutely yeah well
done you know yeah well done very cool
good for you I'm proud of you who was
cheering you on along the way everyone
everyone yeah parents in particular a
lot of people were kind of skeptical of
the concept but once we told them how
close we were and especially when we did
pay everything off it's it's all when
you do it everybody's own yeah
yeah that's funny yeah yeah it's
hindsight's 20 20 for these people yeah
of course yeah good stuff well done you
guys very very well done what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is
persistence grit and sacrifice you can't
have it all right exactly when you want
it yeah and that budget the plan is
there's nothing like being able to look
at at the end of the month and say oh
I've got you know X number a thousand
dollars potentially to throw out my
student loans this month you know that's
we always celebrate a little bit you
know have a drink or something you know
yeah I mean when you can throw 10 grand
at a month at it it's oh it's fantastic
it feels really good yes yeah even if it
is a 400 and some thousand dollar value
where we're gonna get there okay I see
yeah this is gonna work yeah wow how old
are you two and now what are you
dreaming about now the baby boys on the
way I mean it I want people to hear this
so how old are you and then how does
this change your dreams so I'm 34. okay
and I'm 33. wow yep and now we want a
family right I mean that is the dream so
I'm actually going to be taking some
time off work and being a mom for a
couple of years excellent moving to
North Carolina where her parents are and
oh wow changing the whole living
situation everything I'm gonna work from
there uh work from the house so that I
get to spend as much time with their son
as we can yeah very cool very cool see
Dave I love hearing that because I want
people that are new to this whole thing
to realize they can do pretty much
whatever they want this is not just
Financial Peace it is professional
Freedom personal freedom to make choices
like this right and it doesn't even
phase you no a scariest thing for me is
I just never lived outside of Boston
You're Gonna Love North Carolina oh it's
fantastic yeah you're gonna like the tax
change I promise you yes sir that's
another raise yeah wow that's going to
change everything congratulations you
two you're amazing I'm so proud of you
well very very well done congrats
congrats congrats hey we've got the uh
live and give box for you it's the baby
steps millionaires book because if you
aren't one already you will be soon
you're right on track and The Total
Money Makeover book as well and the
financial piece membership if you've not
been through the class go ahead and go
through it for the fun of it now or
teach it or give it to somebody whatever
you want to do it's all for you so thank
you guys so much for coming we're so
proud of you Greg and Meredith Boston
ass at least for now if you live like no
one else later you can live wherever you
want and give like no one else 425 000
paid off in five years making 2 30 to 4
30. count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Fred from deep down
in his guts yes uh that had some power
to it it did well that's uh 425 000
worth of student loans gone that'll get
you that'll get you excited right there
that's right if Sallie Mae is that big
and she's in your house you know when
she leaves yeah that's pretty amazing
that's good wow get the ugly woman out
of my house unbelievable
yeah and and so I mean there's an
example we you know we're talking about
attorneys we're talking about famous
schools and all that there's an example
of someone winning law school debt and
then said I'm not living like this and
leaned in and then made Senior yeah and
as a senior years and both had great
incomes and they worked their way
through it but uh wow pretty incredible
yeah I'll tell you now they've got
choices because I got to tell you yeah
you come out and you're facing down the
barrel of 425 000 and you just graduate
you pass the bar you're married and you
look up you have an oh crap moment sure
here I stand at the bottom of this
mountain and I really don't have a
choice climbing it is mandatory yeah
that's right the only question is how
long the climb is going to take are you
going to do it for 20 years you're gonna
do it for five years that's pretty
incredible they're amazing what a cop
what a sharp couple very cool this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is our
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Daniels in Houston hi Daniel welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so me my wife just started Financial
Peace University we finished the third
lesson and we are trying to figure out
how to downsize we have four vehicle
payments uh my truck her car and we each
have a motorcycle uh we're wondering if
we should voluntarily voluntarily
surrender the motorcycles to get out
from underneath that no I no okay what
do you owe on them
uh so I owe 25 on mine and she owes 17
on hers what's yours worth
mine's worth about 17. what's hers worth
11.
good God what a mess yeah what do you
mean what's your household income
uh I actually lost my job in March and
so we're living off of her salary this
is July what do you do
uh I've been looking for jobs non-stop
I've had seven interviews and nothing's
come from any of them what do you do
um I worked for T-Mobile for the past
eight years I was a regional manager
making what kind of money
about a hundred thousand a year doing
what your regional manager the the whole
obviously operations manager for the
region right uh yeah I was I was over 25
locations okay and you made a hundred
grand Zone huh that's interesting yeah
okay
um and uh I'm gonna Circle back to that
uh let's let's uh what does she make
uh she makes about 88 000 a year good he
works for Exxon Mobil okay let me answer
this and then I will Circle back to the
uh the motorcycles are not the problem
they're the symptom
so here's the problem with surrendering
them I want to surrender them as a last
ditch effort matter of fact I want them
to actually come repo them I don't even
want to surrender them uh because if
that motorcycle is worth 17 when they
take it they're going to sell it as a
repo
for nine
oh okay and you're responsible for the
difference the deficit so you control
the hole that you're in if you sell it
who's the loans with
uh they're through Harley Davidson okay
Harley has run into this before I will
be talking to Harley a lot
okay
um unless they're angry or mean on the
phone and then I just hang up on them
but I'll just be calling them you know
once a week and just giving them an
update that you got laid off and we're
about to get a job and you know this
sucks right now
um we're gonna work it out though and
I'd be talking local Harley dealer and
going hey dude can you get me out of
these
okay okay uh is your credit messed up
uh yeah I'm a 513 and she's a 565. yeah
your credit's screwed okay
yeah
um because I would have you borrow the
difference
because I'd like for instance on yours
okay uh 8 000 gets you out of yours
right I'd have you borrow that
difference if I could
uh if you could find a way to do it
because I'd rather have you eight
thousand in depth instead of 25 agreed
agreed and so yeah but but and that's
the goal is to get there or and or get
you re-employed all right now let's
Circle back and work on the thing the
thing that caused all of this which was
the uh the job thing okay yeah so you
lose your job why'd you lose your job
was it just layoffs or was there
something else no it was layoffs yeah
did you have any Severance at all
I did we we caught up we were behind on
everything we caught up with all that
Severance
um and then yeah just kind of living on
that so are you applying why have you
not gotten re-employed do you think
um I don't know I've been applying for
entry level positions like to clean
bathrooms and I don't get a job
um I've had my resume uh Team the
T-Mobile gave us a service to
professionally do my resume so I had
that done apparently it's not bad
yeah I've had seven interviews and
um some of them were up to the third
round of interviews and then I got
ghosted but are you interviewing for
positions that were similar to the
T-Mobile position
I'm interviewing for absolutely anything
right now okay um like I said I've
applied to work at UH at Bucky's to
clean bathrooms or to to serve food and
I think he's ghosted you
that's like a book title yeah yeah yeah
uh this is I'm not gonna this is tough I
don't know what's going on I don't know
if you're just not interviewing well and
that's not something that I can analyze
right now but you're gonna have to start
diving into your relationships man you
know enough people to be able to get
those people to vouch for you you've got
to get into these interviews where
pretty much you're the you just have to
have a pulse because they've heard so
much good about you and they've got your
friends if this guy's real through these
relationships if Daniel proves to be
real then we're hiring it and that's
what you're not doing you just applying
and getting in the interview process you
have no leg up on anybody else and quite
frankly you're being outperformed in the
interview process somehow or not somehow
I don't know how and I don't want to
because that would be I just don't know
the answer but uh you have got to change
the odds in your favor and the only way
you're going to do that is people
recommending you really advocating for
you not just a loose recommendation but
someone going I know Daniel I'm gonna
open up the door here you've got too
much experience and too much skill set
from that previous job and you weren't
fired you were laid off there's no stain
on you but I'm gonna say one other thing
you need to go get yourself a 20 25 25
an hour job maybe two maybe three listen
Bucky's is hiring gas station managers
the guys for 100 grand I know yeah so
but the point is you got to go get paid
right now like there's no excuse for you
not to be making money in a warehouse
somewhere uh you've got to be making
money by the way managing a Bucky's gas
station is like managing at Walmart
that's no small Endeavor okay so the uh
are you telling me you've been in a
bucket no I'm just you just heard this
is a legendary thing so anyway the um
let's stop all right now we're gonna
send you Ken's assessment
to help you ascertain
your career assessment okay we're going
to send it to you as a gift to free
we're going to send you a copy of this
book that's a quick read or not a quick
reads like it should you should read it
very fast called the proximity principle
and this is what's going to get you in
the door we're also going to send you
his number one bestseller big book
called paycheck to purpose I want you to
read and do this do the assessment read
both of those books in within 72 hours
of the time they hit your doorstep it
will change the way you do this then go
to kencoleman.com and read everything on
there about resumes about letter writing
about getting the interview and about
what to do in the interview Ken trains
people on getting jobs you will get a
job within three weeks of doing these
things it will happen Okay okay he can
he he's the best in the world at this
that's why I've got him out here as a
Ramsey personality so we're going to
give you all that free to help you now
stop on that
sidestep next thing what do you own the
cars
uh on my truck we owe 40 000 and on her
car is 27 000. and what are they worth
uh my truck I had a wreck on mine so
last time I was trying to trade it in
they uh appraised it for about 21 uh in
hers uh was about 17. you guys are just
hearing a mess with these vehicles yeah
okay yeah well so when you are five
years from today when you get uh a good
job and uh you're making a hundred and
she's making 88 you're making 188 and
you get these motorcycles up right side
up and you sell them and then you get
these cars right outside up and you sell
them and then you get into a couple paid
for vehicles uh and you never buy
anything else again that has a wheel or
a motor unless you pay cash for it
you got that lesson right
yes I mean God's got a highlighter out
and he's highlighting this lesson for
you
mm-hmm yeah I mean I can see it clearly
I hope you can because the trick of
doing something stupid and I've done a
lot of stupid stuff Daniel and y'all are
vehicle stupid beyond belief I've done a
lot of stupid stuff my goal when I do
something stupid is not do the same
stupid thing next time if I'm going to
do something stupid it needs to be a new
stupid thing you follow me yes sir yeah
and so that and that's your goal no more
vehicle stupid you got yours completely
out of the way in this chapter of your
life you've got all your vehicle stupid
done never do it again pay cash and buy
conservative vehicles or don't buy them
um and because you got you got serious
Jones for Motors man it's pretty
incredible I know you because I'm the
same way so hang on Austin's gonna pick
up we're going to get you the career
assessment we're going to get you the
proximity principle we're going to get
you the paycheck to purpose book and go
to Ken coleman.com tons of free stuff
there you can start reading that right
now when you get off the phone this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Ken Coleman Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and host of the Ken Coleman show is my
co-host
the first caller up this hour is
Elizabeth hi Elizabeth from New York
City how are you
hi Dave hi Ken how are you great how can
we help
yes hi so um currently I have about 134
000 in student loan debt
um I am a single mom and I've been
following your shows since
2020 and it's it's a pleasure being on
the show we're honored to have you
what's your what's your degree what's
your degree in um yes for undergrad I
did international business and then for
my Master's program I did a dual Masters
in accounting and business families
and you did a dual Masters in white say
again
uh accounting and business analytics
okay so you get did you get your CPA
no I did not why
um because it's very time consuming and
um I did work in the field however just
being in the field for about maybe four
years
um it was in my passion so that's also
why I didn't pursue it
so what do you do now what do you make
uh and I
and what do you make
I've been liking the it Finance what do
you make no what kind of money do you
make what do you get paid oh
yes I get paid
thousand annually okay
all right interesting
okay
uh uh feels like you're pretty
dramatically underpaid
are under utilizing these degrees
feels like someone with a master's
degree in accounting and a sidebar in
analytics ought to be making almost
double what you're making in New York
City why do you feel like you're doing
that
am I wrong probably yeah um you're right
probably
um
um I'll Factor as well yeah
what were you making before
I was making mean 95
000 a year ago you've switched
Industries and went up so your that
theory doesn't hold
what does a promotional path look like
for you have you determined what that
looks like and how long it'll take to
get there
um within the next five years hopefully
I'll get up to a manager position
um definitely long-term director but
it's it's looking you know a little
difficult right now how much history and
how much of a bump would you get at that
managerial level
and are you happy in this type of work
now that you made this pivot
I'm happier
yourself and how many kids have you got
I'm sorry what was that how many
children do you have
one what age
she's about 59 okay do you have a
support system around you to the level
that you could be getting some side
hustle work with all those awesome
degrees you have the gig economy the
freelance opportunities that you have to
significantly increase your income uh
are pretty sizable but do you have the
time or bandwidth to do that
yes I do you need to get busy with that
and you're not on a budget yet
are you
um yes so I've been pretty
um
strength with myself so since like 2020
I paid off my car which was about 25
000 and also I paid off
um another 25 000 on student loans so
originally I had 160 000. okay and
you're down and so you're making
progress and at that rate you'll be done
in about three years
yes and anything you can do to add to
that uh income wise is going to speed
the rate at which you get out of debt
way to go you're you're a warrior get
after it
yes
um but it you know I've been moving a
little bit of momentum
um because it has been a little
difficult you know
um being a single mom and also being in
New York City and the rent is not that
great in price though oh you paid off
while you paid off sixty thousand bucks
that was exactly the same situation
nothing changed
except you're just getting tired
a little bit yeah okay so are you from
New York City
uh yes I agree I grew up in New York
city so your support system is there
your family's there
yes my my family is here all right
if you're gonna stay there this is the
plan
the only other plan would be to move
someplace cheaper and make the same
money
obviously obviously you can live in a
different place with much lower rent
than New York City no kidding and the
other cost of living facts including
taxes and so forth you could save on as
well and if you can make the same money
it would be net net arrays right but you
would lose a support system and you'd be
moving away from your roots which you
may not want to do but if you don't want
to do it you got a two to a three year
path ahead of you and it's gonna you're
gonna be tired but you have 134 thousand
dollar hole to clean up and you've
already cleaned up fifty thousand bucks
I'm proud of you I think you're doing
better than you think you're doing
thank you I really appreciate that um
Dave and Ken it's been you know a tough
battle since 2020 so I just have to keep
the momentum listen hang in there I want
to encourage you you're a mama bear and
I would never bet against any single mom
who has done what you've already done
and you can see you can see the the it's
it's out there but you can see the end
of it think about where you've come from
nine years ago yeah
oh my gosh you're like a superhero from
where you were nine years ago to where
you are now yeah I mean you've got a
double mat you got a double Masters I
mean pretty incredible
you've got the skills to go do anything
you want to do I think you got skills to
make more than you're making I agree and
um especially in in New York City but uh
I think you keep pushing on that keep
working on your people skills as well as
your analytics and your accounting
skills and keep looking for
opportunities and keep scratching and
clawing but I'm with Ken I don't bet
against someone who's already done what
you've already done it's a very very
impressive well played well played this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Samantha is with us in Myrtle
Beach South Carolina hi Samantha welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
hi so I am engaged and I have been for
about two years so we're trying to start
planning our wedding and everything like
that and that means that you know I need
to have some money to throw toward the
right I really don't want to go into
like a massive debt with this especially
since I just paid off my credit cards
and my fiance doesn't have any debt at
all uh so I really don't want to have a
financial burden towards so what do you
mean relationship
I make around 38.
oh God he's uh he's part-time he really
doesn't make that much money he's won a
full-time school right now oh okay
what's she studying yeah
he is studying computer programming when
does he graduate
he graduates
um actually I think December or January
and how old are you two yeah
I'm about to be 22 and he is already 22.
okay
but I also have a I have a car loan it's
around I think I have like 8 800 left to
pay on it and then I also just started
grad school
um so I really uh I just took out
student loans for the first time in my
life and I thought I was gonna throw up
how much how much do you take out
so around each year it's going to be
around 9 000. what are you starting it's
going to be a three-year program uh I am
studying
Child and Adolescent School counseling
and when's the wedding
no women stop hold on you're going to
spend
thirty thousand dollars to get a degree
in Child and Adolescent counseling
so you're gonna go become a licensed
therapist right
hopefully
uh not hopefully you better do it you're
betting on it
right I mean you got to do it right
absolutely but you're not going to go be
a school counselor for twenty four
thousand dollars a year
are you
I hope not I'm gonna try my best to do
but I can with my
um
grad program Dave I would like her to
press pause can you press pause on the
grad program or are you already
committed signed what's the still status
I just started this past month
but I've been out of my undergrad for
like two years
you know that has nothing to do with it
what's the path are you going to be in
the public school system is that where
you're headed
yes yeah that's just not worth it it's
not going to pay you enough to justify
even if you paid cash for it
mm-hmm
you're spending a lot of money to not
make any money that's what we're trying
to say
is that was that registering with you
unfortunately yeah okay
yeah you need to you need to rethink
this okay I don't mind the degree field
as long as you're going to go into
private practice and earn a hundred
thousand dollars a year
um and even then I wouldn't go into
student loan debt to do it I'd be
working like a crazy person or I would
wait until yeah wait until you're
married and he is out making a hundred
thousand a year and he can and you guys
as a couple can pay for your grad work
I'm with Ken I would push pause on this
you already paid the tuition
started yeah okay well how far in are
you can you stop and get a refund yet
um about
often started July 10th you can probably
still get a full refund yeah if you can
get a full refund take a refund and take
a rest yep you're not going to do this
but this is what we're telling you to do
and this is what we do for a living so I
would take a refund repay the student
loan and take a rest until you're
married and then you can cash flow the
same degree field if you still want to
do it at that point but you need
something you need a better path than
public school
with this degree field to justify the
expense of getting this degree this grad
degree this is ill-founded I would not
do it
okay you need to rethink this whole
process and the timing of it you
definitely need to rethink and that way
you can afford at least afford to do it
in the meantime it doesn't cost hardly
anything to get married
you guys go right you know both of you
pile up a couple thousand bucks each and
go have a little party and spend four or
five thousand dollars and get married
if you're going right you know if you're
going to do that that's fine there's
nothing wrong with that at all you do
not need to spend a bunch of money on a
wedding for the wedding to be real or
for the wedding to be correct or
anything else and you guys don't have a
bunch of money he works part-time and
you make 30 grand
and so and if you're going to get
married anytime soon that's what we're
doing
um
yeah and we're gonna you know be aiming
at him graduating in December uh and
then our household income hopefully he's
going to make some serious money our
household income goes way up then we can
reconsider restarting a graduate program
if you've got a way to justify the
expense of it and Samantha please hear
me say
I heard it in your voice you are not a
failure by pausing or by getting a full
refund and just delaying and maybe never
going back Major success please
understand that I could hear it all over
you almost like I started so now I got a
finished note there's nothing broccoli
you don't agree
I don't have to clean your plate it's
start your marriage with as little
stress as possible just press pause on
this
okay yeah and if I were you all I would
go ahead and get married soon yep
two years I mean painter get off the
ladder that's a long engagement
um so this this is you know there's so
much going on here oh my goodness
yeah all right uh open phone so triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Terry's in Denver hi Terry welcome to
the Ramsay show what's up
yeah I'm actually calling because
um
I bought my house it'll be two years in
December
I put 85 percent down wow
um
I sold some property in another house to
buy it cool
um
but my problem is I only met about 4 200
a month I make last year I made 90 000
but my take home
is about 42 to 44 depending upon my
overtime
and the house payment isn't the issue
since the Marshall fire which happened
like a month after I closed on my house
my insurance went up 175 a month
that next year so within six months my
payment had already gone up that much
and this year my property taxes are
going up 30 percent
I've crunched the numbers
and that means my house payment if I did
my calculations correctly will go up
another
100 per month for the property taxes
well that's going to put my house
payment above 30 percent I don't know
exactly yet because it was about 27 when
I bought just a little bit above the 25
so your take-home pay that we talk about
is after only your taxes are removed
and you do not you've got more coming
out than just taxes to get to 4 800 from
90 000. right
I have a retirement yeah that doesn't
count
okay I don't know because I work for a
city yeah but there's a whole no but
that doesn't count that doesn't count in
the formula that we use
okay okay so you know 90 000 would be
maybe
more like six thousand dollars a month
coming on
okay okay not not five thousand okay or
not in our forty eight hundred so so
you're fine you're okay okay
yeah because I called because I didn't
know if I should sell this house and go
down in house or just keep my current
one yeah the trick is to not be house
poor meaning not have so much of your
money going to house payment that you
end up going in debt for the next car
because you didn't save or you end up uh
you know with something not saving for
retirement which you are automatically
out of your check before we even got to
talk about it and so
um all of that so you're able to do the
other things you've got room in this
budget to do it so it's not killing you
at this point the trick is just not to
be housed for that's what the 25 percent
of take-home pay ratio is for so I think
you're fine Terry thanks for the call
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions Brandon and Alicia are with us
hey guys how are you great how are you
better than we deserve where do you guys
live
Lexington Kentucky just right outside in
Mount Sterling cool very good good for
you guys honored to have you how much
debt have you paid off
356 and 63 cents excellent how long did
this take about three years good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh somewhere around 120 to 135 cool
what do you all do for a living I am a
staff accountant for a very large
insurance company I teach awesome what
do you teach this year it'll be
kindergarten wow that's fun well it's
fun she starts her new job in the
morning
oh wow we gotta get you back to
Lexington okay well let's get this over
with quick
good job guys what kind of debt was the
two cars in our house wow
way to go is what's the house worth
probably right now about 2 45. excellent
and how much is in your retirement this
day our total net worth right now is
about 384 000. way to go guys
how old are you two I'll be 41 uh at the
end of August and I just turned 36. all
right so by the time you're 50 you're
going to be millionaires hope so way to
go guys way to go I'm so proud of y'all
good work good work all right what
started this uh episode this journey
three years ago
a lot of resentment actually
[Laughter]
um
honesty right so I was on staff at a
church as a worship pastor at the time
and our best friends uh Jared and
Bethany Childers walked into my office
and said we're going to be teaching FPU
and I said well great good luck and uh
they said no no you pay off your debt
and I said well we didn't have any debt
I was thinking credit cards student
loans we were blessed to never have any
of that just two cars in a house and
they said no you're going to be in it
and uh so reluctantly we signed up for
it and you got ball and told absolutely
that's what it was all right yep I like
it so you got the got into the class and
then all of a sudden you went uh oh yeah
some stuff has to change right luckily
for the cars we actually had the cash
almost all of it sitting and savings oh
wow I'd have just rather paid 800 a
month car payment than to wipe it out
and pay the cars off so so you did wipe
it out and pay the car baby step two
literally took about 30 days okay okay
wow good for you guys and then baby step
three and then tear into the house huh
yeah yes so how much of the 153 was cars
uh 29 000. okay all right so still 120
000 bucks to plow through yeah yeah but
you don't have a house payment man
you're so whacked that's so cool we've
been enjoying this since about April our
goal was to have it done by the first of
July and when we scheduled our debt free
stream in February I looked at her and
said we've got to do it we've just got
to get it done so by April uh we had it
paid off and we've enjoyed a few months
of no house payment yeah the first time
the the month comes around and you don't
have a house payment it's weird isn't it
it is what do you do yeah it's like
surreal yeah it's like I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to give these people all my
money yeah and now I don't have to yeah
yeah that's so cool you really do
believe the borrower slave to the lender
at that point absolutely and when you're
free you know you're a slave sometimes
when you're a slave you don't know
you're a slave but when you're free you
know back then you were asleep I
remember going back and looking through
our text messages from then and she said
oh well what if we don't have any debt I
said well Technic I'm still trying to
convince myself that we dead so well
technically we have two cars in a house
but that's not real debt and now that
it's gone you realize yes wow good for
you guys so fun so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
learn to say no
I'm a big people
pleaser and so it was really hard for me
to learn to tell my friends and family
especially no to stay home and have
staycations instead of vacations and
they you know AO used to say your why
has to make you cry
they've all three of our kids over here
are adopted and their family trees have
already burnt to the ground once and I
want to make sure that didn't happen
again wow I got chills yeah it's pretty
heavy
so when you guys got on the other side
of the car loans what was the momentum
like for that discipline to say no was
it a little bit easier having knocked
out those two things I mean or is it
still very difficult it was it was hard
because like he said the car loans we
already pretty much had the money
and
it was for me it was hard not to give
the kids more to realize that they don't
have to have this that they need this
but not that
they hit the lottery when they got you
yeah to start with oh my gosh yeah we're
blessed we're blessed wow so what were
those hard sacrifices like like Beyond
just saying no to the kids asking for
stuff what are the some of the other
things that you guys do give up a cruise
give up a cruise which was paid for and
that that kind of helped finish baby
step two was we got our money back right
and uh which did not make one of these
children over here very happy and uh so
that would have made me happy yeah so
that that finished it finished it all
for us okay but thankfully this was all
during the covet shutdown we started
baby step
uh paying the house off in May of 2020
so we couldn't go nowhere to do nothing
really anyway so gotcha all right we
just threw everything down we did yeah
we did and through all that process Dave
I guess I owe you some payroll uh
Financial coach I went through the
training they're all over here and some
people from fpus here and uh I'm
thankful for their support through all
this so you became one of the Ramsey
coaches absolutely oh wow absolutely wow
so that that church has always got
somebody now yeah yeah excellent very
cool man great job all right coach yeah
when people ask how you get out of debt
what do you tell them you have to start
with getting on the same page together
it's not going to work if one person's
in one person's out one says yeah sure
do whatever you want to it all has to
start with we're going to come to
agreement that we're going to do this we
can figure out the numbers later we got
to get you together first
[Music]
when he says it it sounds so much nicer
than what I'm saying he does Dave he has
a different bedside manner I think it's
the East Kentucky accent it is it really
is uh no I think you're just a pleasant
guy and Ken your stuff through all this
help I the um the teaching debacle in
the state of Kentucky basically says you
teach for a year yeah we pink slip you
you have to go find a new job so the
proximity principle for three years uh
really helped when when she was faced
with the news that your contract's not
renewed next year that's awesome so wow
we thankful for your proud of you guys
good to you guys I'm proud of you you're
amazing well done 153 000 paid off all
right bring the kiddos up let's
introduce some names and ages
this is Amber she's 11. Braden is 10
Cason is
okay very good very cool all right well
you guys have done a great job hey we've
got the live and give box for you the
baby steps millionaires book because
that's the track you're on we've already
figured that out that's good and The
Total Money Makeover book for you to
give away to a coaching client probably
in a Financial Peace University
membership for you to give away to
somebody so you get to live some of it
give some of it and thanks for coming
all the way to Nashville and I enjoy
your first day of school tomorrow I will
well done well done all right Brandon
and Alicia 153
000 house and everything in three years
making 120 to 135 deciding to do it
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream here we go three two one
[Applause]
for those of you looking deeply into
your radio the kids t-shirts say I
survived FPU yes
it gets it says barely though underneath
and barely so I survived FPU barely
that's awesome Mom and Dad canceled a
cruise and changed our lives house has
paid off
it's great do you have a house payment
what happens if you don't have a house
payment
oh
you become unbelievably wealthy
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day Deuteronomy 8
18 but remember the Lord your God for it
is he who gives you the ability to
produce wealth and so confirms his
Covenant which he swore to your
ancestors as it is today
so here's what's interesting let's just
keep the cement
remember the Lord your God for it is he
who gives you the ability to produce
wealth
that's in the Bible
so those of you that say that that's not
okay from a Christian perspective
haven't read the Bible Albert Schweitzer
says success is not the key to happiness
happiness is the key to success if you
love what you're doing you will be
successful
Rita is in Atlanta hi Rita welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey what's up
not much hey I'm just calling hearing
that that free screen made me um
it's kind of geared towards my phone
call I just want to see get your advice
and opinion to see of what we're doing
if we're doing things right or if we
need to focus on
um one thing so my husband and I are
debts free except for our mortgage and
we're actually only down to about 33 000
on our house and um we have our 401K he
actually was just advised to fund it to
ten percent so do we keep doing that and
we also have
um a car fund that we have a substantial
amount in there
like do I do we pay towards the mortgage
and get that all paid off and then start
um okay so you have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses that's
separate from all of this
and you're debt free but the house
right so that would put you in baby
steps four five and six
baby step four is putting 15 of your
income towards retirement it said I
thought you said 10 are you doing 15
somewhere else so uh yeah we have an IRA
um that has more money in that but this
is just what through his company where
his company matches up to six okay so
have you got 15 of your income going
towards retirement in some form
yes okay then that's baby step four baby
step six is pay off the house you only
owe thirty three thousand and you also
would save and pay cash for your next
car so if you have a pile of cash
sitting there this earmark for the car
uh that's fine or if you decide you want
to change the name of that fund from car
fund I want to pay off my house fund I'm
okay with that too how much is in that
fund
the car fund we have about fifteen
thousand okay and what's your household
income
number 100 and what's your worst car
that you're replacing
um a 2005 but it only has a hundred
thousand miles on it it said um
a can of Dodge Cannon truck pickup truck
so it's got a lot of life even works
from home yeah it has some life and I
drive a 2010 minivan with about 170 000
miles okay so choosing between paying
off the house or throwing the 15 at the
house and having 18 left or upgrading
cars there's not a wrong choice here by
our steps it's a matter of preference uh
then you've got to decide what you want
I gotta tell you just looking at it if
I'm in your shoes it's gonna be real
hard for me to not reach over and try to
knock that house out yeah that's what my
husband and I we were tempted to go up
there because we've had some issues with
the van we're attempted to go upgrade
the van but then when we we got our
payoff amount where I thought oh my
goodness we're so close and actually we
have closer to the six months maybe even
a little more in our emergency fund so
you could dial that down a little even
yeah and throw some more at it yeah and
then be done right right you could be
done with it and then upgrade the van
with no house payment later
right I mean it's not that you never
upgrade the vanishes that we're going to
pay off the house first rather than buy
their van first right okay I mean you
could do either one I'm I'm not you know
I'm just I'm thinking with you is all
I'm doing I'm not telling you because
according to the guidelines that we have
you're gonna be fine either way because
for five years from today you're gonna
have an upgraded car and a paid for a
house regardless of which direction you
go
okay because you're in control you're
being very intentional you're careful
you're thoughtful you're talking about
it together you have all the symptoms of
somebody who's gonna win
yes okay
okay so you're not that stupid you don't
stupid column is not in this discussion
right right
good job really good yeah really
incredible incredible and I you know I
like how you said there's no right or
wrong here and I want people to hear
that because I'm sitting there listening
to that I'm going there's options again
it's real options when you've got a car
that's you know 170 000 miles on it it's
been a pain in the butt for them
recently sounds like but to your point
if they dial that emergency fund back to
three months plus what they've got they
may knock that out completely then all
of a sudden they're replacing that car
in three months I like that options
Erica is in California hi Erica what's
up
I can I can hi Dave how are you guys
doing great how can we help
okay um
um where I'm at and what I should be
doing we are technically on baby steps
well I take that back I guess we've got
five thousand dollars in debt which
credit card debt which we need to pay
off first
um that is through my husband's business
so I'm not exactly sure how to tackle
that because I don't handle those
finances but um we our house has paid
off
we don't have any outstanding debt aside
from my husband's business five thousand
dollar credit card bill
um but he recently ended his partnership
with his uh
with for his company and now his income
is significantly reduced and so we're
spending more than we're making and I'm
not exactly sure what to do moving
forward in the next few months ahead of
your job
well he's got one he's just he's
sure he's
he's owned manufacturing engineering
company which it looks like it's going
to be doing well
um we're just not making as much as we
used to currently and we haven't even
spend as much as you used to you got to
get your income up or your out go down
you're not in Congress
right right
things are necessary expenses like child
care for example we're spending thirty
four hundred dollars off our two kids as
it is so he's not making any money well
well he he's together our household
income right now is a hundred thousand
he thinks you can't live on a hundred
thousand dollars
and you have no debt no house payment
yeah
right well as I that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm trying to figure out
more necessary it's all of our necessary
expenses no you don't have a hundred
thousand dollars of necessary expenses
with no house payment and no car payment
and no student loan payment
you don't have that
it's not there
one of these numbers is wrong
okay you know I mean seriously yeah
that's eight thousand dollars a month
I agree with you I'm just I we you know
we've sort of fallen off the wagon with
not being able to track our expenses
you're not on a budget but you're not on
a budget you need to get on every dollar
I'll put you in every dollar premium if
that'll help you that'll hook you up to
your bank and you can run your budget
and you and your husband need to sit
down and run your budget I kind of think
the way you've covered for him twice or
three times in this conversation that
he's really not making any money yet but
you're pretty sure he's going to you
have a lot of faith in him and that's
good I like that but I don't think he's
making any money today is he
you know the problem is Dave is he's
telling me that just hold on at the end
of the year we'll be able to make this
distribution and it'll cover everything
no it won't cover everything because you
got to pay daycare this month daycare
doesn't do until the end of the year so
he's not making you don't make a hundred
thousand dollars yet
well that's he's taking out he's taking
out an income he's taking out an income
he's giving himself a salary So
currently our salary is a hundred
thousand dollars but again I'm finding
it it's it's leading and I I just I'm
having trouble between child care and
all okay I'm having trouble
understanding is this guy's really
making a hundred thousand where the
crappies get why you okay if he's really
pulling a hundred thousand dollars out
of his company and you really have eight
thousand dollars or seventy five hundred
bucks hitting the bottom line over there
and you guys can't live on that with no
debt y'all got other issues and so hang
on I'll get you signed up for every
dollar get the two of you to sit down
you both need to understand where this
is going on this promise with a
distribution at the end of the year is
bullcrap okay if you can't make your
monthly bills and you got no debt so
hang on we'll get you signed up that
that puts this hour of the Ramsey
showing the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]